we do you know what you know what
saturday so here's the thing about miami
their spring break and the spring
breakers who are from florida yeah
came there and [ __ ] the entire
operation up [ __ ] up because the city
went on lockdown
i heard yeah so we couldn't find food or
anything like that everything was
shutting down like
early shut shut down so so we weren't we
couldn't find food like i post mates it
wouldn't come it's just a nightmare
mine did because i went vegan he went
vegan which i'd rather just starve
so where did you move i had seven
pringles for dinner in miami
i said here's my [ __ ] dinner thanks
miami but it was a good time it was the
game
you can suck this california dick yeah
he did so then
um at the restaurant my boy lex
was doing business uh no lex my manager
okay guys but he's really close to the
the manager of the hotel in an
intercontinental
name's uh veronica so they have a uh
one of the top steak houses miami there
called toro toro
toro toro and they're chicken wings
daddy
oh my god i know right yeah god they
were good
but so they would leave the kitchen open
for us after the show oh yeah
so we had great steak you ate there cat
you and stevie had it it was so good
yeah yeah oh yeah how about that dessert
is this chocolate ball and they drop it
on the table it shatters
there's like ice cream and all this [ __ ]
yeah like drop it on the ball
he goes everybody say bon bon three one
two three bomb but he goes
cause the ball is made out of chocolate
so shattered yeah it shatters
the food was so good there it was good
and dog miami
everybody got an ass everybody everybody
got ass in miami
miami is my probably one of my top
favorite cities you weren't ready for it
i was not ready
i've been there before everywhere you go
there's a
[ __ ] dime piece with a blowout app
everywhere
everywhere i i i i was stressed for the
girls with flat asses like were they
gonna do yeah
what are they gonna do and they weren't
really there you couldn't really find
them there so you could tell the
out-of-towners with the flat
yes dude even tsa even tsa
9 a.m i look in chicago
dude look at the [ __ ] yeah just out
of control
i don't [ __ ] control she was just
yelling at people she wasn't
take your water out throw your water
away
that
dude we go to the mall we get coffee we
go to walgreens
we went to cbs ass ass ass ass but
there's also
do you consider that everyone's on
spring break or just no no no
i think because we weren't on south
beach we visited it and i'm not a fan of
south beach that's like coming to l.a
yeah
he's not a fan that's like going to a
walk of fame or that's like going to new
york going to times square
yeah then jay's tourist ass
oh let's go to versace's [ __ ] hotels
it was kind of it was the most tourist
picture i think we've ever joined
such a turn let me tell you why it was
jay idea because he's smiling and y'all
just looking we're on
i was like he's all yeah look at jay
smiley look at y'all
y'all like man he's so happy
because i don't know why
stuff i don't like turkey stuff i hate
her [ __ ]
i can tell y'all went to coffee and jay
was like nah let's go oh yeah
first of all we walked to here's the
thing you could tell we're from l.a
obviously vinelli hat on
yeah just me and chappelle scream la
we're the only people on south beach in
pants
and pants yeah everybody like we looked
so out of sweats
i'm in sweats and then i have to hide my
raging boner because there was smoke
shows everywhere we were at
everywhere i took that thing now man
also i saw y'all on jet skis as well man
i read the jet skis for the squad
hell till you're real slow like
the guy just pulled up because where our
hotel was right on the on the water yeah
so the guy
they just pull up in three jet skis and
we get off things like teach us how to
do anything can you swim out you're like
a fish dog
he was cool i can't yeah you guys so so
if your friends get in trouble you're
gonna have to help them that's what we
do
but i was terrified because i thought
them [ __ ] were going to tip oh you
didn't know
no so i was just like they were like
[ __ ] full throttle
and well jj went racing one of the
funniest moments i just see
jay filming and brendan doing [ __ ]
town
oh going crazy
you're being a dad cause i was trying to
catch up
that's so funny also wait jay took you
out to the hood
i went to little havana by myself to the
marlin stadium got this dope ass marlins
jersey
they decided to go out on their own yeah
so we got on these scooters
because we he jay was like we got to go
to this art district yeah
i think it's called wynwood when would
you when would our art district or
something like that yeah
the night before james was like let's go
to the art district like what are your
instagram
said yo that used to be the hood like
that you know it's probably the art
gallery
yeah so i guess they gentrified that
area but it's still really [ __ ] good
and so me and jay
caught the scooters early in the morning
riding over there the scooter stopped
when we got in the hood oh they already
knew bruh it beeps they're
bro and then it just shuts down so like
we
we're sitting here in the middle of the
hood and we're like not gentrify the
scooters
yeah first of all first of all i'm like
jay let's just leave the scooters yeah
he was like what he goes what why i was
like i was like if we just leave a
scooter it's only a hundred dollar fine
[ __ ] it and he was like no bro jay's
cheating we had
we had to go a mile and a half back just
to be in an area where
you had to drag it no we had to like
push oh
dude and it's and it's heavy manual yeah
they're heaviest and jay was like he
goes i'm not gonna pay a hundred dollar
fine i was like jay a hundred dollars
i was like i'll pay your hundred dollar
fine
yeah yeah like [ __ ] with ease but
yeah because we were so
close like we were just right in the
hood yeah and then the art gallery was
just right there
even though he's just gonna sit there
and be like no let's let's let's take it
it's just a waste of time
but even with the ufc like i want to
watch ufc in the back and we have to
sign into our airspan plus
jay was like yeah i want to pay for this
thing man i was like you better pay for
this [ __ ] thing he's like
i'll just find a stream like [ __ ] you
better pay for it
rita's like i paid for the jet ski
what your bully does look at these big
guys man and then
jay tried to scare me say they were
[ __ ]
he was like there's tiger shark
chappelle he's dead stairs he goes
chappelle there's tiger sharks
everywhere i'm saying so don't fall off
i went what's wrong with you
no i said i already paid for this you're
going to scare him out of [ __ ] going
here's what i wanted to [ __ ] be like
nah dawg
but then i jumped in the water oh yeah
you jumped i lost my sunglasses those
ray bans which i love
i lost it because you jumped in i forgot
i had them on and jumped in the water
swimming around
and i could just hear jay going you know
there's tiger sharks in the water so i
got the [ __ ] out
but yeah after a while i started hitting
the full throttle
okay okay yeah i see with your arm up
and everything yeah yeah i was feeling
myself after a minute because
uh yeah i just thought those things
tipped easy why does brenda's look
bigger than yours
i had the big boy yeah he had the big
yeah he had the big boy okay what'd you
add me and jay had the
same one like a car seat i guess so [ __ ]
it was comfortable for me bro and then
there was dudes with their baddies on
the back just [ __ ]
ass is out
just instagram thoughts on yachts all
around around waving at us
and [ __ ] bro it felt like you're here oh
you're embarrassed
i'm all slowly doing donuts to you over
here it was so funny watching jay just
film it was like the most big brother
moment ever he's just
kill me
but did you ride jet skis before though
yeah yeah yeah that was my first time
well we could tell oh you went slow hell
yeah yeah
damn but i love miami dude bruh i got it
that's my [ __ ] city
i mean shout out to miami we didn't try
cuban food though
because [ __ ] everything was like
closing i know did you go to like
by the clevelander area yeah we walked
by there okay we went to open locker
did you know every it was so funny
because every fan
came up to me that that came up to me
after the show they're like don't go to
openlock
they're like i love malik and they all
said don't stay in opel
man i got family out there shout out to
opel what is this open block of the hood
or something yeah it's kind of like that
but it's newest gentrified
you know i'll tell you what i'll tell
you who we didn't see besides stephen
cat
stevie and kate you know miami's open
year round
you guys don't need to go when we go we
didn't see
justin
we didn't hear from him no again justin
you know miami's open year round
like i don't you know he can go whenever
the [ __ ] you want
i was like nah we're going to enjoy this
vacation yeah justin was doing the
goddamn thing yeah he was
yeah not at all no not at all barely
you'd show up like late show everything
then and then while we're outside
waiting for uber he's he drives up
y'all all right and then we're like oh
we could really use a ride he's like
you're in your mom's
[Applause]
we're literally standing there waiting
for this uber human as [ __ ] outside
is gonna say y'all good y'all all right
and just take off all right
but those shows were lit man well how
you walk outside every night
literally walk out the crowd every night
and they're just like [ __ ] lit
and also the most beautiful people i
think i've ever seen you know how
usually my crowd's like
all [ __ ] cocked dude it was just
filled with
diamonds out of all weekends i know you
didn't know
all the weekends i just want to see i
want to live no yeah because uh
because some of the uh i was standing by
the merch table with jay
yeah and so many girls were asking for
like a big girl
and he was like we normally don't bring
it because it's always dude it's just
always dudes and online girls at the
shows but like
there were so many uh women which i'm
like damn this never happened no it's
not like i've been touring with this guy
since june it's all good it's always
it's my dad did y'all see salt bae who's
that
oh he owns the restaurant out there and
he's shut down who sat down
i think dude and why i mean shut down
like thursday night we're like that's
not a big deal we'll go back
over there but the bars were closed at
like midnight like
shut down because listen i think all the
spring breakers yeah the curfew they
came from atlanta
tour atlanta then they went to miami
yeah because they're not from like
florida people when i mentioned on the
show they'd boo the [ __ ] at them because
they're oh that's
everyone's like they're not from here
man those are out of towners [ __ ] up
the city
damn oh this this guy this guy yeah yeah
yeah oh
and he has hills they call him salt bay
yeah i know that's what they
what's his real name cause i feel cool
he got real famous doing that
[ __ ] and remember that one he feeds that
one dude the girl in the dudes
what the [ __ ] she's like deep throating
that [ __ ]
fillet what yeah she's like what in the
[ __ ]
any uh uh salt bae try to deep throat uh
pulse uh the guy amore cooper for dallas
and he was like man i'm not with all
that yeah
i mean oh so that's oh yeah yeah he's
famous for doing that
but he's probably a really good cook
though i'm sure yeah probably
yeah world-renowned chef
yeah he's yeah he's putting salt on
there he's making millions
of that knife like that and he's out of
miami yeah he's in miami yeah
i think i literally can't get over miami
[Music]
damn was was he famous before the whole
the way he did the song that's what made
him huge
but he's obviously a [ __ ] world
record chef yeah
man cook for the best man i thought
y'all was gonna go out there man
we probably would have if everything
wasn't so locked down like you didn't
want to try doing that
and then we had the the contact that
toro toro so we just kept going yeah it
was
it was just cool and it was great food
but that last night saturday
we we ate fat because we got diet we ate
fat we got done late
and they were like hey we just left food
in your room so we thought all the boys
would go back and eat so it was just
food for me
fried rice wagyu [ __ ]
yeah the burgers burgers the [ __ ] uh
this uh the sausage that you know that
sausage that we had
yeah sauce y'all just went crazy oh man
sitting there watching bad teachers just
laughing and giggling yeah
zoo culture in the morning but yeah we
were there in the morning we were there
we were there
just for a tour of miami all right yeah
that place was dope yeah we we got it
yeah we got to hit miami again
right okay it was just i will never go
back during spring break though
oh that's literally like the worst which
time to go okay because
yeah well i think it'd be better next
year everybody just wanted to escape
you're showing it together in spring
break no that's not yet yeah
that's not i don't know when they have
their chill moments of miami but
yeah i don't know this the spring
breakers yeah did make it we were the
uggles people on south beach we were the
ugliest people there it was like zoo
cultural
yeah yeah we can't explain it you can't
escape y'all gotta constantly get
reminded it's just like oh i gotta
accept this [ __ ] and then you go to the
zoo culture on monday where the ugliest
in the yeah yeah
everybody got beautiful accents and [ __ ]
man i'm like
in miami even the dudes yeah but even
the dudes are like
[ __ ] chiseled had the most clean
lineups oh and how about the versace
outfit
outfits we're in [ __ ]
long story short yeah you wearing
sweatpants
i said you ain't gonna wear those on
stage
please don't wear that on stage
on stage with goddamn bradley's uh wrong
yeah yeah
rocky please don't walk around please
jean jackets you can't even wear jeans
like you'd i didn't pack enough
underwear i'd go through three underwear
a day because you're so
so happy you just want to shower all day
you just want a shower okay we did walk
around with our shirts off
uh oh after the after the jet skis
though he's walking around well yeah
y'all didn't care
we let him hang out yeah yeah you had
girls on yachts you had dudes
yeah you wasn't
i haven't walked around like in public
without a shirt on
you know how was it was the first time
coming out yeah first time coming out i
was like
you had those short shorts on yeah i did
had these short shorts on i was feeling
myself leaving it living his best life
yeah new sunglasses new sunnies
new sunglasses to give me wait what
james glasses well mine looked dope and
i know jay has a million sunglasses i'm
like [ __ ] gift
because he was like i'll send you the
site i'm like too [ __ ] yeah
those sunglasses they said i would see
you today
i'll send you the site that was right
there you're gonna be done i think
chappelle posts on his instagram
what'd you say your new sonny's
no you didn't send me that picture
really no you didn't post any picture of
it no you didn't send it to me
damn why you so stiff in that picture
which picture that one
because he said pose and i said all
right oh word
i'm almost at that hundred thou oh are
you up there i think i'm almost
there yeah yeah i remember doing a
giveaway once you get a hondo yeah once
i get to a hundo
almost there almost there bro you how
about that when i get off stage at the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son